[Musik]
carmen muri wurde 1906 als tochter eines
arztes in adelboden geboren das berner
oberland war der schauplatz ihrer jugend
schon früh sorgte sie für aufsehen im
dorf
morris weg führte weg aus der idylle
nach london berlin paris und schließlich
ins kz
1947 stand kamen mori in hamburg vor
kriegsgericht angeklagt wegen
misshandlung und tötung von
mitgefangenen im kz das urteil tod durch
den strang
[Musik]
spannende dem vk memory schluss meiner
sicht dass sich frage stelle ob sie es
grundschulen ist worauf zu eines
unrechtssystem ihnen geraten und das
renovierte der maschine oder ob sie so
verschiedene etappe in einer kriminellen
karriere
abklopfen ist und wo sie dann am schluss
im kz schlimmste dort wird er deutlich
vor manche mitgewirkt hat
[Musik]
manchmal kommt es mir vor als sei ich
noch immer nicht nach hause
zurückgekehrt das alles ist jetzt 50
jahre her doch man ist gezeichnet fürs
leben
noch heute denke ich täglich an all
diejenigen die ich sterben sah davon
kommt man nie mehr
[Musik]
im frauen konzentrationslager
ravensbrück nördlich von berlin wurden
über 100.000 frauen opfer der nazi
willkür
ungefähr die hälfte von ihnen kehrte nie
wieder nach hause zurück
die frauen wurden entweder zu tode
gequält oder vergast oder sie starben an
krankheiten entkräftung oder kälte
im dezember 1946 eröffnete die britische
militär justiz den ersten prozess gegen
verantwortliche des kz ravensbrück
deutsche ärzte kommandanten und ss
aufseherinnen standen vor gericht aber
auch die schweizerin kamen muri als eine
von drei ehemaligen kz häftlingen
ich habe wohl die vorstellung gehabt
dass carmen von mir also eine
entlastende zeugenaussagen erwartet hat
das konnte ich einfach nicht das habe
ich also eine sehr ausweichende antwort
gegeben ich könnte leider nicht sehr
viel zu ihr sagen weil ich nicht zu
wenig kennt wenig gelegenheit gehabt
hätte und ich nehme an dass sie dass sie
enttäuscht als sie aber zumindest also
einen sehr enttäuschten traurigen bösen
wütenden blick zugeworfen der mir auch
weh getan hat natürlich die
ordensschwester isa vermehren war vor
dem krieg eine name auf der junge
kabarettist in berlin gewesen
1944 wurde die unerschrockene nazi
gegnerin verhaftet man brachte sie ins
kz ravensbrück
wo auch carmen mori einsaß
wenig später lernte auch die
französische ärztin lilia carmen mori im
kz kennen
sie schien mir bei guter gesundheit
sie war gut gekleidet viel besser als
wir übrigen häftlinge sie trug stets
einen elegant geknüpftes kopftuch
ich war verblüfft dass sie sich als
deutsche ausgabe
sie sagte nicht gleich zu anfang das die
schweizerin war von ihrem äußeren her
schien sie der mediterrane typ sie hatte
einen dunklen teint und dunkle braune
augen
zieht aus südfrankreich aus nordafrika
oder aus dem mittleren osten stammen
können
leidenschaftliche augen in denen sie
viel temperament sichtbar wurde sehr
viel zorn und wut und auch erheiterung
natürlich wenn wir was zu lachen haben
sehr viel sehr viel temperament leben
lebhaftes temperament und
ich denke mir dass er eine frau gewesen
ist wenn man sie
nicht ganz so in einer verzweifelten
lage gesehen hat
[Musik]
carmen muri stammte aus adelboden
anfangs des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
mauserte sich das dörfchen im berner
oberland gerade zu einem kurort von
internationaler ausstrahlung
am aufschwung des kurorts hatte ein mann
besonderen anteil kamenz vater emil mori
der bärtige etwas bayerische arzt war
der hauptinitiatoren
kurvereins
morris ideen waren manchmal konfus und
politisch unkorrekt doch schon früh war
er es gewohnt sich um jeden preis
durchzusetzen
jahrelang hatte er ein wildes leben als
schiffsarzt geführt bis ihn eine malaria
von asien zurück in die schweiz zu kurz
war
mit 43 verliebte sich mori in eine fast
20 jahre jüngere verheiratete frau
tochter eines schweizers und einer
philippinin die frau ließ mann und drei
kinder sitzen und gebrauch mori nochmals
drei kinder
1906 kam kamen zur welt
[Musik]
kaman war die mittlere von drei
schwestern die eltern lebten aber oft
getrennt harmonie gab es zu hause wenig
als kamen vier jahre alt war starb die
mutter unter mysteriösen umständen
sie wurde tot in der badewanne gefunden
die familie lebte schnecker glücklich
sie und auch noch dollar verlust gemacht
dass das diesjährige
jetzt schon
analytics einfach sehr darunter gelitten
dass die mutter mikro
und nachher die steppe die fußball trafo
miteinander gespielt und und gesteht
dass sie
ganz plötzlich dunkle den kram
mutterschaft philippinische service und
die lästigen egal ob sie oder das ist
für
weniger die länder kennt sich also
bestens hinter klasse stehe
dies sei maximal
konfirmandenunterricht sony pad ist
macht sie hätten noch mal jetzt sehen
wir noch potenzial wird glaube darum
nicht
naiv 814 kannst du hier fabriziert und
liberaler menge steht maske dass sie
aber nicht nur sie könne
sich durch europa zu sorgen
carmen muss als kind mit ihren gefühlen
sehr allein gewesen sein der verwitwete
dr mori machte seiner tochter das leben
nicht einfach an seinem haus ließ er
lateinische sprüche anbringen die ich
lasse mich bieten aber nicht brechen
damit beeindruckte mori die adelbodner
brüskierte sie aber auch carmen
entwickelte sich zur bald anziehen den
bart gefürchteten einzelgängerin wie
bradley spezielles lustiges chor hatte
ich davor in der billigste textil muss
ich es lacht auch sie und hat im
winterhalbjahr
habe schotterstraße ich gerade meine ich
habe gerade modische gegangen mit
und dann hat sich aktion spring der
straße
doch nicht verrückt ich will ihnen doch
nicht auf 4 44 meter straße und nächte
da bleib ich dem fc
auch durch die sprinter haben und die
schnittfolge nicht mehr benötigt da
durch führungen und da ich glaube sprung
unterbrochen und die klagefreudigkeit
dass die spitze der schule eine partie
mehr bestritten oder so das hat sie zum
beispiel die wetterfahne grünert sie ist
im stark sie und hält zwei biber trend
der saison
mehr oder weniger
was hat sie schon können
sie hat sehr ab ist
eine internationale gästeschar
verkehrter in adelboden und speziell im
haus des kurgastes
die junge kamen machte interessante
bekanntschaften und entwickelte ein
ausgeprägtes sprachtalent das aufregende
leben im kreis der illustren gäste aus
aller welt zog sie den familiären
zwistigkeiten vor
[Musik]
dass sie mit
das später gesagt dass ich damit hätte
sie ihr kann
aber ist die attraktiv sie ist so schön
trug sie so spielt fans mit lag sie nach
silvester wenn sich luft verschafft die
stasi alle sozialen unterschiede ganze
fremdländische tipps wie
man hier wollen wir die hürde des
yorkshire harthausen
sobald sie konnte ging kamen von zu
hause weg sie fand unterschlupf bei
bekannten in amsterdam und london nur
noch selten kam sie nach adelboden
mit 25 versuchte sie es mit einer
gesangsausbildung in münchen
1932 tauchte sie in berlin auf
berlin schien kamen nur zu behagen sie
suchte und fand anschluss an die reichen
und schönen ihrer zeit
die nazigrößen die hier ihren einsatz
für die bedürftigen inszenieren waren
zum größten teil im poker menge
sie waren berauscht von ihrer
plötzlichen machtfülle
1934 lernte movie den berliner
polizeipräsidenten graf helldorff kennen
helldorff machte ebenso blendende wie
korrupte geschäfte mit immigranten
pässen kamen mori interessierte dabei
nur ein gesellschaftlicher glas die
dazugehörige ideologie nahm sie in kauf
[Musik]
mori fand unterschlupf bei einer
verarmten großbürger familie die villa
immerhin war der witwe von werner und
ihren zwei fast erwachsenen kindern
geblieben gegen etwas bargeld vermutete
man zimmer eins davon ankamen mori die
stets knapp bei kasse war
die ganz wertvoll war damals wertvoll
und soja und konnte eben auch brahms
lieder von brahms sagt immer hoch
musikalisch zuerst ein paar andere
verdächtigt ich weiß noch fast nur
schlimme sache aber dann um schulden und
nachher waren die fun scheide irgendwo
gefunden worden den damen kamen uri
haben sie nie erwogen sie aus dem haus
zu werfen wenn sie da werden na ja papa
gemacht aber die wahrheit wieder da
plötzlich
ja
und dann hat sie sich so liebe dort mit
wunderbaren lieder dieses sagt war als
phase ein bisschen war selber
künstlerisch
künstler und wissenschaftler wie
nobelpreisträger max planck verkehrten
damals im hause von werner mit größter
selbstverständlichkeit beherbergte die
familie auch einen jüdischen bildhauer
als mieter mann war offen und freizügig
in jeder hinsicht
dazwischen war die jugend machte feste
machte wie die carmen tötete sich die
haare an dich war das war kam in den
coaches
rate ich die haare angezündet hat
getanzt ich habe ja auch immer gerne
braucht tänze gemacht und so also das
war dann aber ganz tolle
einer der prominentesten liebe männer
seinerzeit war der pilot ernst udet den
kamen mori noch in adelboden
kennengelernt hatte mit seinen
fliegerischen kunststücken verblüffte
und weltweit das publikum
carmen mori frischte die alte beziehung
in berlin wieder auf über udet der
gerade frau göring zum geburtstag
gratuliert fand sie zutritt zu
einflussreichsten nazi kreisen
mit goebbels traf sich mori mehrmals
einmal auch mit göring spätestens 1937
arbeitete sie als agentin für die
gestapo fotos von mori gibt es ab da für
lange zeit keine mehr
also der ns staat ist ein spitzel starb
sie in der anfangsphase hat die
regierung viel informationen über die
politische gegner wähler muss findet
machen drum hat gstaad wo viele junge
menschen angestellt zum der politische
gegner zu bespitzeln carmen mori hat so
eine manipulative kassierte schon vorher
gemacht im zusammenhang mit ihren
geldsorgen und hat dem vater brief
geschickt und ein andere angeschwärzt
also sie hat das schon früher gemacht
und jetzt hat sie plötzlich
klarheit kaum mit der fähigkeit in
office und schlusszeit geld verdienen
die hat um sich herum gestohlen
kleptomanie nennt man das heute
und da war immer mit dieser
agententätigkeit des ging dann immer
quer durch waren sogar zwei schweizer
kapital waren dabei und die sagten
nehmen sie sich ihr nacht am besten gar
nichts zu tun mit der frau sie arbeitet
für eine bestimmte stelle also das war
ja
eben doch sehr gut ausgedrückt
axel von werner marines bruder wurde
vermutlich das erste opfer der agentin
carmen mori
axel hatte ziemlichen erfolg bei frauen
er arbeitete als filmvater bei der ufa
auch mit carmen mori schiene ein
beiläufiges verhältnis gehabt zu haben
wieder star unter den jungen leuten war
das nun mal was passiert und wie bei
bruder also arztrechnung freute da
wartete starrte ihn irgendwie verpasst
hast du die hatten was zusammen ja
scheinbar
aber beim bruder wand und besonders
erzählt er wie das war die jungen leute
haben sich dank getroffen und da will
sie eben auch zusammen ins bett gegangen
hab ich mal nicht
ihr bruder ist ja an verschiedenen
oliver decke stau produziert wurden von
ihr wussten sie das ja das mussten wir
immer ahnte ja alles wird sagte für die
judenverfolgung und so es war ja alles
so unter einer decke und man musste es
anders weil ich so dass das alles
vielleicht schrift da stand nicht
axel von werner kam die bekanntschaft
mit der gestapo agentin carmen mori
teuer zu stehen
er bezahlte sie mit seinem leben
[Musik]
wie viele andere deutsche war auch
marlene dietrich vor dem totalitären
regime der nazis ins ausland geflohen
[Musik]
marlene dietrich benutzte paris als
plattform gegen die nazi-diktatur in
paris hat aber auch die parteipolitische
opposition gegen hitler ihren sitz
ende 1937 wurde kamen mori von der
gestapo nach paris geschickt sie
beschattete hier zwei vertreter der exil
spd eine davon mit namen helmut klotz
wurde später ins kz buchenwald
deportiert dort hat man ihn wie willy
brandt bezeugte bei lebendigem leib
gevierteilt
es ist auch interessant die ganze als
auch unserer perspektive vor nach dem
kriege
es hat verschiedene untersuchungen und
rantrum in oestrich wo man gesagt hat
was hat das denunziantentum bewirkt die
militär kriegt hand also effektiv die
taktik denunziation verbrecher die hand
auch der betroffene vielfach zum tod
geführt die sie in die kasse griff wurde
uns interessante bei der studie sie
zeigen das biete eine denunziation
verbrechen der anteil von der frauen
sehr hübsch mehr als elf die vor der
täterinnen sind sie
kurz bevor die deutsche armee im juni
1940 in frankreich einmarschierte wurde
kamen mori von den franzosen verhaftet
und als spionin zum tod verurteilt
doch zur hinrichtung kam es nicht moore
wurde zu lebenslänglicher zwangsarbeit
begnadigt
im zuge der deutschen besetzung konnte
mori aus dem gefängnis fliehen und
schlug sich nach deutschland durch
[Musik]
doch die nazis trauten mori nicht mehr
nach einigem hin und her wurde sie von
der gestapo verhaftet
schließlich landete mori im lager
gefängnis des kz ravensbrück
folterungen waren da an der tagesordnung
war ein oder zwei zellen weiter meine
eigene zelle und von daher konnte man
das auch hören dann nicht also das war
unangenehm was sie haben sich sehr
sicher
man hat schreien können man alles schon
gehört man hat doch die kommandos
schlimmen gelegentlich gehört von denen
halten die dabei war
von zellen bei hellhöriger als man sich
das vorstellt mori hatte etliche
menschen der gestapo ans messer
geliefert nun erfuhr sie den naziterror
am eigenen leib dann musste sich der
häftling auf einem block legen und wurde
dann von einem anderen häftling mit
einer peitsche
bearbeitet oder anderen häftling wurde
ja nie ein häftling natürlich da suchte
man sich schon die richtigen aus können
sich vorstellen der arzt stand daneben
fühlte den puls und gleichzeitig zu
sagen jetzt ist jetzt ist ich glaube ich
genug und sie war also
da hat sie mich mich zu zeigen ans
fenster gerufen wie sie davon zurück
kann mit ihrer zelle mit einem blutenden
rücken können sich vorstellen
und ohne dass man sich um sie gekümmert
hätte
und da hat es mir entsetzlich leid getan
weil das ja auch kann das ja nachfühlen
wie weh das tut wie entsetzlich
verlassen und verloren sich ein menschen
vorkommen muss nicht in einer zelle aus
der nicht draußen rein können also das
war schlimm
doch auch im kz schaffte es kamen mori
sich durch intrigen und denunziationen
aus dem schlimmsten heraus zu mogeln
muri wurde von der lager ss zur
blockwart in ernannt sie beabsichtigte
nun als häftling eine überfüllte baracke
mit tuberkulose kranken frauen
als blockwarte verlangte sie strikte
ordnung und sauberkeit
gegenüber den mitinsassen war sie
knallhart egal ob die krank waren oder
nicht
mir gegenüber hatte sie nicht respekt
aber eine gewisse distanz vielleicht
weil ich ärztin war aber die meisten
insassinnen hat sie den lieben langen
tag angeboten
sie war sehr unberechenbar an gewissen
tagen war sie sehr gut ich meine in
ordnung doch dann gab es tage an denen
sie äußerst gewalttätig sein konnte in
worten oder
wenn man uns im lager jeweils in großen
eimern die suppe brachte möchte sie das
beste davon für sich heraus bevor sich
irgendjemand anders bedienen konnte
aber wie schon mal an
ich bin ziemlich sicher dass sie jemand
war der auf zwei schultern getragen hat
somit durchaus mit dem blick auf den
eigenen vorteil im mr
mit dem blick auf den eigenen ford hat
man die wollen ja überleben du lieber
gott das wollten wir ja alle nicht und
ich nehme an dass sie sich in ihrer
situation
wieder überlegt hat welches ist der
sichere weg für mich zum überleben aber
dieses auf zwei schultern tragen weil
eben doch sehr gefährlich und
nicht jeder hat das geschick gehabt dass
bis zum ende so durchzuführen dass er
heil raus kam und dafür war sie glaube
ich auch zu leidenschaftlich im
ernstfall dann auch zu unüberlegt in
ihren reaktionen
wenn man nicht dass man ihnen das nicht
sagen wir mal nicht so sehr
charakterlich oder moralisch zum mars
fliegen kann sondern
sie hat nicht früh genug gelernt ihr
temperament ein bisschen zu üben
einmal musste ich miterleben wie sie an
ordnete eine junge polin umzubringen die
geistig schwer verwirrt vor meinen augen
hat sie ihr eine spritze geben lassen
weiß nicht genau was drin war jedenfalls
ist die frau tot zusammengebrochen
wegen dieser spritze
ja unmittelbar die medial
[Musik]
gäste und was machten sie
was können wir tun gar nichts konnten
wir tun wir konnten uns ja nicht
zwischen sie und die kranke frau werfen
sie war diejenige die befahl
was mich persönlich angeht ich habe mich
geweigert die spritze zu verabreichen
aber sie hat natürlich eine gefunden die
es tat
[Musik]
es sind die toten die man in den
waschraum brachte nachts kamen die
ratten und sicher nützlich zu tun
riesige hatten
[Musik]
hätte sich auch ganz anders verhalten
können der beweis dafür ist ihre
nachfolgerin eric buchman eine deutsche
kommunisten sie war für alle eine
ausgezeichnete baracken chefin
erika hat nur gewisse risiken auf sich
genommen
sie erfüllte ihre aufgabe als sogenannte
blog älteste aber sie war allen
gegenüber gut und versuchte das leiden
der kranken zu lindern
ich habe eine blog älteste kennengelernt
in diesem blog in dem ich war die fand
ich fabelhaft die war so unparteiisch
die war so gerecht die war so
menschenfreundlich die war so
überzeugend auch in ihrem auftreten die
hatte das sehr gutes verhältnis es also
ohne jeden falschen kompromiss die hatte
große autorität bei den häftlingen und
auch bei der ss wegen ihrer integrität
und ihre absolute verlässlichkeit und
diskretion also man konnte das sehr sehr
anders ausfüllen dieses amt
ab kamen wo er hätte also ihre aufgabe
ganz anders aussehen können
ja bestimmt sie hätte uns eigentlich vom
revier die paar medikamente bringen
sollen sie uns zustanden und wenn ich
sie danach fragte sagt die sie immer es
gebe keine gut fiel war das sowieso
nicht ein paar aspirin tabletten
manchmal so von emmi tabletten oder ab
und zu kohletabletten für frauen die an
ruhe litten aber sie gab mir nichts sie
behielt alles für sich
und was macht sie damit
und sie brachte sie für sich oder gab
sie ihren persönlichen bekannten denn
sie hatte gute beziehungen im lager
gab es auch handel mit medikamenten ja
wahrscheinlich aber wissen sie kamen
muri war extrem geschickt man ertappte
sie nie auf frischer tat ich glaube sie
war sehr intelligent
im curio haus in hamburg verhängte das
alliierte militärgericht unter seinem
präsidenten dem englischen generalmajor
west drop dass urteile über die
verantwortlichen für das
konzentrationslager ravensbrück das
größte und furchtbarste frauengefängnis
der geschichte 16 männer und frauen
hatten sich wegen unmenschlicher
behandlung und ermordung von tausenden
von häftlingen aller nationen zu
verantworten
die angeklagten wollten 1 und vorgeführt
und ihr urteil entgegen zu nehmen zum
tode durch den strang worten verurteilt
johann schwarz huber der ehemalige
lagerkommandant von ravensbrück
die ehemalige ss-aufseherin dorothea
binz
carmen maria mori deren abenteuerliche
laufbahn sie zu einer zentralen figur
des prozesses werden ließ insgesamt
verhängte das militärgericht in elf
fällen die todesstrafe die übrigen
angeklagten erhielten langfristige
freiheitsstrafen
konnte mir damals eigentlich nur sagen
dann hat das also offenbar doch
bestimmen dass man hier nach gesagt hat
wir hatten ja alle das vertrauen das die
englische gerichtshof eigentlich sehr
unparteiisch ist nicht selber ja keiner
darunter der selber hatte aushalten
müssen also und dass die sich mögen
aussage gegen aussage abzuwägen
da hatte hatten wir eine also ich ganz
sicher so das vertrauen das wir hatten
gut begründetes urteil sein
und natürlich fand ich das schrecklich
dass das sie da so rein aber wenn sie
wie gesagt nur beginn agenten nach
beiden seiten war und im lager auch nach
beiden seiten versucht hat sich zu
arrangieren war das eigentlich
unvermeidlich
das ist natürlich die schlimmste strafe
ich denke sicher verdiente sie eine
strafe aber die todesstrafe gegen
vielleicht zu weit
warum denken sie dass die
tiefsten beweggründe der menschen kennt
dann eigentlich nie stand sie vielleicht
selbst unter einem wir nicht sagen
moralischen aber doch begeisterten hat
die sie vielleicht selbst auch angst vor
den deutschen
jedenfalls glaube ich dass man sie zu
einigen jahren gefängnis hätte
verurteilen können ohne gerade soweit zu
gehen
sind sie prinzipiell gegen die
todesstrafe
nein ich glaube dass die todesstrafe in
bestimmten fällen berechtigt sein kann
aber im fall von carmen mori hätte ich
den mut nicht gehabt sie zum tod zu
verurteilen
was
wäre das alles nicht selbst erlebt hat
kann sich gar nicht wirklich vorstellen
und der rechner druck man dabei andauern
stammt und die menschen sind halt das
was sie sind wir haben angst und tun was
sie können und ihre haut zurück
kamen mori die sich seit ihrer haft in
frankreich zum katholizismus bekannte
hatte auch während des prozesses ihr
temperament nicht im griff mit
ungeschickten äußerungen und vorwürfen
sorgte sie zwar für aufsehen in der
öffentlichkeit stieß aber die richter
vor den kopf
die höchststrafe war die logische folge
auch wenn nur morris taten im kz
berücksichtigt wurden marie wurde
weggefahren in die todeszelle
[Musik]
ist das ist der zieht wo sie verstarb
und hat sofort nach dem krieg militär
krieg griff oder verschiedene alliierter
wo das
haben viele bewältigen das unrecht zu
stehen und es sind 530 personen lag sie
verschiedene eines verbrechens vor
deiner vollständig sind 800 zum tod
verurteilt wurde das zeigt die
proportionen es zeigt dass das nicht
außergewöhnliches ist und es sind auch
sehr viele exekutiert worden in der
ersten phase nun muss aber gleichzeitig
dass die gericht mitte zieht milde worte
sind also vergleichbar personen wo im kz
tätig sind sind zwei drei jahre später
zum tode verurteilt wurde oder sie sind
zum tod verurteilt worden man hat an die
strafen immer vollstreckt
insofern ist es also auch pitts wie
jedes bach sie dass sie das so gerade in
der ersten blick prozess in kroatien ist
carmen mori hätte durchaus eine chance
gehabt dem todesurteil durch die briten
zu entgehen die engländer hatten nämlich
noch vor dem prozess angeboten mori an
die schweiz auszuliefern doch der
bundesrat war die affäre peinlich dass
entsprechende interne gutachten empfahl
hände weg die engländer sollen das weiß
selbst zur verantwortung ziehen
in diesem gefängnis in hamburg
verbrachte carmen mori ihre letzten tage
den tod vor augen
eine karriere die mit ein paar
kleinkriminellen taten begonnen hatte
endete begünstigt durch den krieg in
verrat und tötungen das etikett
todesengel war an ihr haften geblieben
morris rechtsanwalt stellte noch ein
gnadengesuch
der schweizer konsul in hamburg empfahl
unterstützung doch der bundesrat zögerte
das gnadengesuch wurde abgelegt
am nächsten morgen fand man orie tot in
ihrer zelle
sie hatte sich die pulsadern
aufgeschnitten
[Musik]